bonsoir gilbert collard merci d'être
avec nous cette décision de suspendre
les vols
enfin si j'ose dire sous la pression
politique d'ailleurs plus que celle des
soignants que moins de succès sur ce
coup là on imagine que vous saluer cette
décision allait trop tard selon vous a
coûté dot
c'est la cacophonie bon c'est si c'est
triste c'est c'est désespérant mais ce
gouvernement ne gère que le désordre et
son propre des ordres en plus en a le
ministre délégué aux transports monsieur
djebbari qui vient pompeusement comme
s'il était professeur de droit dire dans
un premier temps pour ne pas interrompre
les liaisons aériennes avec le brésil
pour des raisons juridiques pour des
raisons de droit l'imperium du droit en
scène quand ce qui lui a apparemment qui
avait l'air de penser ça non c'est le
conseil d'état c'est pas le droit le
conseil d'état c'est une juridiction qui
appliquent le droit administratif
mais on se rend bien compte que ce n'est
pas du tout vrai dans la mesure où
monsieur castex qui ne piétine pas le
droit que je sache
sous la pression politique a
décidé que les vols seraient annulés bon
donc on a affaire à une cacophonie
on a l'impression qu'ils se parlent pas
entre eux quoi qu'ils n'arrivent même
pas d'une pièce alors à coordonner leurs
points de vue leurs analyses et
franchement ça créé une panique mentale
dans la population parce qu'on se
demande si il y à un pilote dans dans
dans l'avion et il sait que pour
atterrir il faut sortir le train
d'atterrissage
quand vous pensez que en est on est
enfermé dans des frontières de 10 km et
qu'on met un temps fou pour se rendre
compte qu'il faut fermer les frontières
afin d'empêcher que le virus soit
transporté remonte remontant quelques
quelques mois en arrière
on nous reprochait quand nous disions
qu'il fallait fermer les frontières
extérieures de faire preuve quelque part
de xénophobie virale on nous disait les
les virus n'ont pas de passeport
bon faut maintenant tout le monde sera à
l'évidence que pour éviter parce que
c'est tellement le bon sens qu'ils
commandent qu'on ne comprend pas qu'on
l'ait pas entendu avant tout le monde
s'accorde à dire il faut il faut fermer
les frontières pour éviter la la
contamination des zones à risques bon on
est dans une situation de désordre
absolu percolation ferme pas vraiment
les frontières on suspend des vols et
sachant évidemment que ce variant
brésilien il est présent dans 37 pays
dont quasiment toute l'amérique du sud
la sortir de restrictions beaucoup plus
strictes à l'aéroport ici il faut éviter
à partir du moment un endroit est
localisé comme étant virulent ne porter
d'invariants virulent il faut bien sûr
empêcher la pénétration à l'intérieur du
territoire il faut protéger les les
l'intérieur de la guyane de toute force
de pénétration illégale massive venant
venant du brésil également bien sûr il
faut protéger nos populations
mais c'est pas compliqué à comprendre
tout de même on mais c'était trop tard
la gaine et déjà atteindre parce par ce
variant écouter ça a été trop tard tout
le temps voilà c'est le gouvernement du
trop tard trop tard pour les marches
quant au début on nous disait qu'il
fallait pas emporté trop tard pour les
lits de réanimation alors qu'on s'était
promis d'en créer quinze mille puis
douze mille et qu'on a toujours pas les
lits de réanimation nécessaire trop tard
également pour les vaccins contre caen
avait été capable de produire quand on
voit sanofi qui s'installe à l'étranger
il ya de quoi il ya de quoi désespérer
bon trop tard pour les tests aussi qui
ne sont pas disponibles partout trop
tard pour les vaccins à propos desquels
on ne sait pas lequel dépend lequel est
mauvais comment il faut le prendre si
ces deux doses trois doses on voit que
les vaccins fighter et astrazeneca ont
été approuvés en quelques semaines alors
que pour le vaccin spoutnik il faut près
de douze treize quatorze 14 mois à 12
mois bon donc on n'arrive pas à
comprendre la manière dont dans ce
gouvernement gouverne c'est un
gouvernement un gouverner aujourd'hui
clairement au rassemblement national
qu'est ce que vous demandez il ya encore
quelque chose à a demandé où ça aussi
c'est trop tard écoutez on leur demande
d'arrêter leur d'arrêter leurs conneries
je peux me permettre c'est pas mal hein
c'est pas dans le droit constitutionnel
mais ça dit bien ce que ça veut dire que
une fois pour toute ils cessent de
croire en la communication comme étant
une solution qu'il qui le qu'il prenne
la réalité à bras le corps
regardez le confinement il n'est pas
intervenu pour finalement intervenir
regardez les élections régionales et
départementales ils ont tout fait pour
les reporter non pas pour des raisons
sanitaires
mais parce qu'ils ont peur d'afficher
une déculottée électorale
il serait temps que ce gouvernement se
rende compte que la vie est tragique
je sais pas tout gilbert collard m'en
parler de ces élections régionales
puisque il ya eu un soutien massif à
rester avec nos deux là
mais on va le voir sur ces images pour
le maintien de ces régionales et
départementales en france seront
seulement décalée d'une semaine un vote
symbolique les députés avec 443 voix
pour 73 contre et 13 abstentions le
premier ministre qui a donc précisé que
des consignes particulières serait
donnée pour les personnes âgées à
mobilité réduite ou ayant des
comorbidités des bureaux de vote qui
pourront également être placée en
extérieur demain ce sera au tour du
sénat de débattre sur la question
gilbert collard clairement l'exécutif a
dû céder à la pression des autres partis
a concédé qu'elle serait maintenue
ces élections il à l'exécutif a tenté un
coup notamment en interrogeant les
maires au dernier moment dans des
conditions d'impolitesse qui ont choqué
du reste les élus et en espérant obtenir
de ses élus surpris qu'ils allaient dire
que les élections devaient être reportés
les maires n'ont pas du tout dit cela
ils ont dit que bien au contraire il
fallait maintenir les élections
maintenant posons-nous encore la
question
alors qu'on sait qu'il va y avoir des
élections depuis très très très
longtemps
ça c'est un fait qui tombe du ciel on
savait pourquoi n'at-on pas déjà mis en
place les mesures d'organisation
pourquoi faut-il tenter un report échoué
dans cette pratique politique pour
décider d'organiser les élections qui ne
sont pas encore organisé alors qu'on est
à deux mois deux mois et demi des
élections
voyez aussi c'est tout ce ce désordre
qui fait qu'on se dit que véritablement
il n'y a pas de coordination il n'y a
pas de prise en compte du réel il n'ya
pas d'anticipation ou et le traitement
ou et le traitement parce qu'enfin on
parle beaucoup des vaccins mais rendez
vous compte que healy à débat sur les
vaccins d'abord sur l'efficacité sur la
manière dont ils doivent être
prescrit appliquée mais il ya aussi des
bars sur l'absence de traitement alors
que des médecins nous disent qu'il ya
des traitements
pourquoi on a abandonné la thérapeutique
pour ne laisser que l'hôpital récupérer
les malades dans des cas très graves qui
vont en réanimation quand il ya des lits
parce qu'il ya pénurie de ligne voilà ce
qui est ce qui est terriblement
angoissant et que ce gouvernement paiera
merci qu'il ne prend pas les choses au 6
rue
merci gilbert collard député européen et
rennes merci d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france